borderlands so wird die landfläche
genannt die in der vergangenheit mal
zwischen nordeuropa und großbritannien
lag doch vor 10.000 jahren begannen
gletscher zum schmelzen und die nordsee
verschluckte die landbrücke und mit ihr
auch alle lebewesen die sich nicht in
sicherheit gebracht hatten und damit
höchstwahrscheinlich auch menschen
jetzt fahndet eine forschungsexpedition
nach steinzeitlichen siedlungsspuren in
deutschland hat sie ein untergegangenes
reich unter wasser entdeckt klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierend des seins videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasste nichts
herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
die landbrücke mit dem namen dockland
erstreckte sich kilometerweit von der
ostküste englands bis nach südschweden
den niederlanden und dänemark in dieser
landschaft lebten früher mal
säbelzahnkatzen mammuts und fällen
nashörner
denn auch wenn es heute schwer
vorstellbar ist bis vor etwa 10.000
jahren waren weite teile der heutigen
nordsee trocken doch dann begannen zum
ende der eiszeit vor rund 10.000 jahren
die gletscher zum schmelzen und der
meeresspiegel stieg stück für stück an
dazu vincent jay der zu diesem thema
forscht wohl tausende von jahren haben
die menschen im süden nicht bemerkt dass
die küste immer näher kamen dann ging es
plötzlich recht schnell und sie haben
wahrscheinlich gesehen dass das land das
sie als kinder kannten plötzlich
verschwunden waren alle lebewesen die
sich dann nicht auf die britische insel
oder aber ins innere von europa gerettet
hatten gingen dann wohl mitsamt ihrer
heimat unter übrig blieb damals also nur
eine insel und zwar der höchste punkt
von dokument das wohl ursprünglich mal
23.000 quadratkilometer groß gewesen
sein musste 8000 jahre ist es her dass
dann ein gigantischer tsunami dafür
sorgte dass auch dieser letzte
rückzugsort zwischen skandinavien und
großbritannien überspült wurde
doch fest steht dass die landschaft hier
mal sehr fruchtbar war und so gehen
forschungsteams weltweit davon aus dass
auch menschen mit sehr großer
wahrscheinlichkeit das eiszeitliche
talent besiedelten einzelne funde von
fischern liefern hinweise darauf der
ganzen sache soll jetzt aber
wissenschaftlich auf den grund gegangen
werden und zwar durch das projekt lost
frontier ist schon im vergangenen jahr
hatten die fachleute zumindest teile von
dowland kartiert und zwar mit hilfe von
seismischen messungen und borken und
diese analyse enthüllte beeindruckende
informationen über die landschaft denn
das versunkene talent bestand demnach
nicht nur aus marsch gebieten küsten mit
weißem kalkstein klippen sondern auch
aus flusstälern und hügeln und
bohrkernen daten sprechen dafür dass
eine region etwa 80 kilometer nördlich
der holländischen küste von menschen
bewohnt gewesen sein könnte und zwar zum
mittelsteinzeit die experten und
expertinnen schließen das aus den funden
die im sediment der sogenannten braun
bank gemacht wurden hier in dieser
untiefe nehmen der das wasser 18 bis 20
meter tief ist konnten nicht nur
menschliche knochen aufgespürt werden
sondern auch bearbeitete tierknochen und
steinwerkzeuge auch ein großer see wird
hier vermutet was den bewohnern und
bewohnerinnen damals zugute gekommen
sein könnte
eine britische belgische
forschungsexpedition hatte sich anfang
mai zur braun bank aufgemacht um gezielt
nach siedlungsspuren zu suchen mit den
detaillierten untersuchungen die das
team im mai 2009 10 durchgeführt hat
hoffen sie die einzigartige geschichte
dieser landschaften weiter zu
entschlüsseln auch in diesem rahmen
werden so nah kartierungen vorgenommen
und sediment bohrkerne entnommen und
nach dna von tieren und pflanzen gesucht
immer im hinblick natürlich auf mögliche
indizien für die präsenz von menschen
zudem sollen auch videoaufnahmen vom
meeresgrund sowie bodenproben dem großen
rätsel um talent auf die schliche kommen
laut der fachleute könnten erfolge ein
ganz neues kapitel der geologischen
erkundung eröffnen dass das ganze
projekt ist nicht nur mit viel arbeit
sondern auch mit etwas glück verbunden
dazu winzingen wenn man mit einem nur
einen meter großen greife eine
landschaft von der größe hollands
erkunden will gleicht die suche nach der
nadel im heuhaufen das glück fehlte der
expedition bisher denn starker sturm und
wellen führten zunächst zu einem abbruch
der arbeiten das meldete das
forschungsteam auf twitter dennoch
gelang es große datenmengen zu sammeln
diese warten jetzt auf ihre auswertung
und könnten vielleicht dazu beitragen
dass das große rätsel um talent gelüftet
wird konkret suchen die fachleute nach
spuren von menschen
aus der mittleren steinzeit also jäger
und sammler die zwischen 11.000 und 5000
vor christus lebten diese hatten
vielleicht sogar eine eigene kultur
entwickelt über die heutzutage rein gar
nichts bekannt ist also quasi ein
eigenes reich dazu vincent jay wenn wir
erfolg haben wird dies das erste mal
sein dass jemand nachweise für
siedlungen in den tiefen wasser der
nordsee findet das wäre eine echte
premiere das wäre brandneues wissen über
etwas das man tatsächlich als verlorenen
kontinent bezeichnen kann und dann
hätten die forscherinnen und forscher
tatsächlich ein uraltes untergegangenes
reiche entdeckt wir bleiben dran und ihr
bleibt am besten bei uns dran wenn ihr
hier drauf klickt das einzig sichere
aber nur auf tellern werden über jedes
video informiert und zwar bevor es hier
auf youtube online geht und es gibt
diskussionen kommt mir können selbst dem
vorschläge machen und uns bei allem bin
ich dabei zudem gehört es nicht zur
facebook datenkrake und man muss seine
telefonnummer auch nicht preisgeben wir
sehen uns aufstellen würde ich sagen bis
dann bleibt dran